we have the one and only meet Canyon
he's subbing in for Cody man because
Cody man is on the honeymoon making
sweet sweet love right now I don't know
why I think he's [__] right now yeah
let's look at the time what time is it
in Tuscaloosa Alabama
what a place that's my that hey that's a
[__] that's a honeymoon yeah he's out
in Tuscaloosa right now okay yeah doing
some mud with the boys with the boys
yeah down there in the south of the boys
look at my bride it's 1 p.m there right
now see I don't think he's [__] do
you do a lot of morning [__] morning
no way man that's the only time I know
how to make love is in the morning at
4am yeah 4am it's like a construction
worker I wake up
[__] alarm rings it's go time